claude blanchemaison heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france alors
quelle est la stratégie de l'otan en
afghanistan
bon mais c'est ce que mon rôle puisqu'il
est à la veille d'une réunion en
visioconférence des ministres de la
défense de l'otan est en effet le temps
se trouve devant un choix crucial
respecter l'engagement pris par les
américains vis-à-vis des talibans de
retirer l'ensemble de leurs troupes au
mois de mai au risque de finalement
laisser les talibans prendre le pouvoir
les talibans contrôlent déjà plus de la
moitié du territoire afghan
ou bien ne pas respecter à ce moment là
et bien cela servirait d' excuses aux
talibans comme ils l'ont dit pour
redoubler les violences mais les
violences n'ont jamais cessé
alors en réalité on voit bien que les
américains ne remettront pas en cause
leur engagement de retrait simplement le
calendrier pourrait être remis en cause
il pourrait glisser il ya encore vous
l'avez dit 2500 soldats américains en
afghanistan et ne serait ce que pour des
raisons logistiques
il faut je crois trois mois pour
organiser le retrait des hommes et du
matériel qui les accompagnent et les
trois mois et bien on y est
donc il est probable que le calendrier
va glisser et que c'est ça que monsieur
stoltenberg préparé par ses déclarations
reprises sous une autre forme par
monsieur clinton le nouveau secrétaire
d'état américain alors le modus vivendi
entre américains et talibans c'est à
dire moins violent ça pendant le retrait
des troupes est il en train de voler en
éclats non puisque l'accord du 29
février de l'année dernière 2020 est un
accord très important puisque
l'administration américaine avait
s'était engagé à mettre fin dans le fond
à 7 à cette intervention en afghanistan
qui dure depuis qui durait depuis 20 ans
ça fait beaucoup et en effet
l'afghanistan est connu pour n'avoir
jamais cédé devant des troupes
d'occupation
toujours est il que cet accord prévoit
en effet qu'il n'y aura plus d' attaque
directe des troupes américaines par les
talibans et en contrepartie les
américains se sont engagés sur un
retrait total de leurs parts au mois de
mai et puis troisième élément c'est
l'engagement d'une conférence entre les
talibans et les différentes tendances
politiques du de l'inca distant et
notamment avec le gouvernement officiel
de kaboul
alors ces éléments effectivement sont
plus ou moins respecté c'est à dire que
les talibans n'attaque plus directement
les troupes américaines mais les
violences redoublent c'est-à-dire qu'ils
attaquent les armées officielles de
l'afghanistan et qu'il y a très
régulièrement des attentats tout à fait
meurtrier donc évidemment cela peut
servir de deux d'arguments pour retarder
le retrait des troupes américaines est
un peu là le dilemme devant lequel se
trouve washington
si washington qui va décider ça n'est
pas vraiment la conférence de l'otan de
demain et où en sont les discussions
entre le gouvernement afghan et les
talibans
alors ces discussions sont très
difficiles
les afghans ont l'habitude de ces décès
et de ces six rencontres sans fin entre
entre responsables afghans de
différentes tendances
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères
abdullah abdullah qui était candidat à
d'ailleurs à l'élection présidentielle
contre monsieur achraf en est plus ou
moins le président le président de la
conférence de réconciliation
internationale c'est un ancien proche du
commandant massoud et il a beaucoup
d'expérience politique
mais effectivement les afghans veulent
certainement se libérer de les troupes
étrangères qui sont sur leur territoire
mais d'un autre côté le risque est que
les talibans en profite pour revenir au
pouvoir et que la charia soit de nouveau
imposé suivant l'interprétation talibane
à la population qui ce qui serait
évidemment extrêmement difficile
extrêmement dure et ce sera un échec de
l'intervention de la coalition
internationale
ce serait surtout dur d'ailleurs pour
les femmes puisque les talibans avaient
pris des mesures extrêmement dures qui
même interdisait aux jeunes filles
d'aller à l'école
donc c'est ça les enjeux qui sont
actuellement sur la table et il est
probable que cette conférence interne à
lille on va continuer à discuter sans
pour autant arriver à un accord de
partage de pouvoir
les talibans veulent que les américains
sans die que la coalition s'en aille et
mesurer le rapport de forces avec
monsieur achraf avec le président actuel
de l'afghanistan pour en réalité
reprendre le contrôle du pays
merci beaucoup claude pour votre
éclairage claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales